since you've been out
uh i even got some dope features on the
project obviously oh yeah for sure
i think it's dope you you and stupid
young linked up oh yeah you see somebody
that's my boy i know i've been
he's great yeah i've been i know him
from jail though yeah he's a good dude
man
um alex who has who has tapped in with
you
uh since you've been out that that
you know there's like your story was
very high profile
yeah so a lot of people knew what was
going on so has there been any artists
that have tapped out since you got out
to try to work
oh yeah uh rowdy hit me uh like a lot of
people that have been hitting me though
like
uh jay chris uh what
uh it's so many people um the what's
made in tokyo oh yeah uh
um a lot of people like reaching them
but i already had songs
how crazy was it to witness roddy's uh
ascension to stardom while you were
locked yeah that's just crazy because i
was like
because when you when you i think when
you got when you got like he was making
some noise yeah he was yeah but like he
was like yeah but he wasn't like yeah
i mean last night around that time now
he's one of the biggest artists on the
planet yeah i've seen it yeah i heard
the box but
i knew that song was going to blow up
when i heard it i was like
that's your heart so is there going to
be a rottie record coming i don't know
man you got a example
that'd be big for the city man yeah
that'd be big bro
i'll just be focusing on what i got
going on because worried about what
other people got going actually gonna
stress you out and throw you off your
game you gotta worry about yourself